oh I've never seen this guy in my life
yes so today we're gonna be walking
through a Union Square giving people
surprise fourth grade quizzes to see if
they're smarter than a fourth grader
that's good
welcome to New York the study space but
stays on earth astronomist
[Music]
trick question
definitely not Scientology an
astrologist final answer astronomer
astronomy astronomers yeah so completely
orbit the Sun one day 365
366 one day that was my first answer
[Music]
he's handsome
that is our vice president
that's my pence the Vice President of
the United States I would say yeah his
first name was Mike the kids would've
paid no I don't know who that is who is
it
I think he's part of military I mean I
know he's like in the government at some
some point but like I don't know who
that is
Mike Pence is the sort of vice president
there's probably pence liberation right
does have anything to do with health
susan b anthony do too I have no idea
but I'll make a guess susan b anthony i
have no clue what she did to help other
women the vote with slavery like voting
rates suffrage rights yeah suffrage okay
[Music]
jay-z jay-z jay-z it's all over the
place
so the real question is that can you
write jazzy and cursive I haven't done
curses since like this Xperia Z in
cursive Jesus
[Music]
why is that cheating it says Shawn
Carter I did not do well I was relieved
that it was fourth grade questions I
think taking a fourth grade test was
refreshing I've seen a bunch of videos
online where they take people decide to
ask these questions and they give
ridiculous answers so I just didn't want
to be one of those an astrologist I
think I am one of those now say yeah
[Music]
you